[Musique]
Véronique prince Hélène buzetti allait
castonguet bonsoir
bonsoir constitution
débat Québec
Ottawa et Ottawa Ontario aussi d'une
certaine façon je vous montre quand à
Joël Denis Bellavance monsieur Trudeau a
dit on répétait bien dit écoutez on va
peut-être effectivement demander à la
Cour suprême d'encadrer l'utilisation
par les provinces de la clause des
rogatoires regardez ça quelques minutes
après la publication ou presque monsieur
Legault entre autres te dit cette
volonté manifestée par Justin Trudeau
est une attaque frontale contre la
capacité entre nations de protéger nos
droits collectifs
aujourd'hui je vous fais écouter
réaction monsieur Trudeau et les
conservateurs puis on revient
je crois que beaucoup de politiques
évidemment que la course prime à moi
dire mais reste de à la base de vouloir
initier une procédure de révision c'est
une commande politique de la part du
Premier ministre et c'est pour ça comme
je dis on va prendre le temps de
regarder exactement c'est quoi
l'intention mais il reste que le on voit
qu'un jeu politique de la part de
Monsieur Trudeau pour provoquer le
Québec entre autres
bon Hélène bussetti y a-t-il un jeu
politique de Monsieur Trudeau pour
provoquer le Québec
ça se peut vous savez moi ce qui me
frappe quand même c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il y avait quand même une tentative de
dégonfler tout ça comme pour dire c'est
pas nouveau ce que je dis je l'ai déjà
dit alors qu'en fait le discours fédéral
libéral fédéral a beaucoup évolué sur le
sujet rappelez-vous que la loi 21 la loi
sur la laïcité à l'origine de tout ça
adoptant en 2019 on se retrouve en
campagne électorale fédérale à l'automne
2019 et Monsieur Trudeau nous dit NON
NON j'interviendrai pas dans une
contestation
2021 une autre campagne fédérale aux
arbres peut-être et là on arrive en mai
2022 il envoie son ministre de la
Justice David la médecine au front nous
dire oui finalement je vais intervenir
peut-être même sur la loi 96 celle qui
porte sur le la langue puis en passant
toute cette idée là de clause
dérogatoire utilisé de manière
préventive ça nous tourlupine on regarde
ça ce qui fait que 8 mois plus tard
quand monsieur Trudeau fait lui-même la
déclaration il a beau de souffler le
chaud et le froid finalement ils disent
qu'il a à dire ce qui est une petite
bombe dans le fond quand on y pense mais
en même temps il nous dit ben c'est pas
nouveau donc calmez-vous et donc c'est
une façon de progresser sans jamais se
mettre personne à dos mais évidemment
que à Québec ça ne peut pas passer comme
lettre à la poste et mais monsieur
Trudeau réussi quand même un certain
exploit faut quand même le dire lui qui
porte ce patronyme là que longtemps été
synonyme de pourendeur de la nation
québécoise et bien le voici qui nous
annonce candidement qui va contester une
loi que certains pourraient dire
identitaire provenant du Québec sans que
ça crée de débordement en dehors en
dehors de la sphère politique
autour de la table au Cabinet fédéral il
y a beaucoup de gens qui s'inquiètent de
l'utilisation par ailleurs de clauses
des rogatoires par le Québec mais pas
juste par le Québec l'Ontario le fait
récemment et que c'est des gens qui
philosophiquement même à l'époque de
Trudeau pair était contre qui a une
clause dérogatoire en disant on peut pas
un droit est un droit est un droit et
une majorité ne peut pas éliminer des
droits aux minorités
de la clause qu'on a fait le Québec
celle que vous voulez le faire l'Ontario
et on s'inquiète de ce que voudrait
faire l'alberto aussi faut pas les
oublier dans l'équation Daniel Smith qui
a déjà dit vous savez nous on pourrait
utiliser cette clause là pour protéger
les intérêts supérieurs de l'Alberta
éventuellement donc à Ottawa on commence
à trouver que ça commence à faire
beaucoup de provinces qui
prennent un peu à la légère peut-être la
suspension des droits fondamentaux de la
Charte dans certaines circonstances et
qu'on voudrait peut-être l'encadrer non
pas interdire l'utilisation par les
provinces ça c'est dans la Constitution
c'est immuable à moins que tout le monde
s'entende pour une réforme
constitutionnelle et c'est pas prêt
d'arriver donc c'est vraiment l'aspect
préventif l'utilisation des de cette
clause là avant même qu'il contestation
devant les tribunaux qui fait des bas
j'écoutais l'un de parler un petit peu
la stratégie de la grenouille qui est
dans son chaudron puis beau et
tranquillement qui sera pas compte
finalement que le débat est rendu plus
loin que que qu'est-ce qu'il est
réellement parce que parce qu'à Ottawa
ON moi ce qu'on me dit aujourd'hui c'est
quantawa on est un peu surpris à des
Rulence de la sortie de François Legault
et de son ministre en fin de semaine en
disant comme les lunes le dit mais
pourtant Monsieur de la médecine en
avait parlé on avait un peu télégraphié
ça au moment au dogford en a parlé
pourquoi soudainement d'une attaque
envers la nation québécoise et là c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on essayait de
vous savez peut-être pas été très clair
mais oui ça fait un moment qu'on
pourrait aller vers cette question là
mais c'est un beau c'est un beau tu es
beau théorique on sait pas ce que la
course suprême pourrait rendre comme
jugement pourrait dire aux politiciens
vous savez nous on se mêle pas de ça à
la construction rédigé-la comme vous
voulez c'est pas notre problème alors on
est très loin d'un encadrement mais
l'idée seulement d'en parler c'est clair
que pour le Québec et pour certaines
parties des politiciens qui tiennent
beaucoup à l'utilisation de cette clause
là ça fait déjà c'est politique il y a
toute philosophiquement il y a beaucoup
de gens ou que Louise Arbour qui on
parlait avant Noël elle est pour que
l'on précise à quel moment on utilise la
clause de rogatoire c'est pas de
l'enlever au province mais de l'utiliser
avant dans un projet de loi avant que la
joute se fasse devant les
disait-elle c'est une façon d'empêcher
un débat devant les tribunaux qui est
sain également dans une démocratie donc
cette opposition philosophique entre la
majorité qui se gouverne dans un
parlement qui a le droit de faire ce
qu'il veut et de l'autre côté
la défense à tout prix de des droits
individuels elle est là vers un éclacé
c'est un débat politique intéressant
même oui et ici on fait la façon qu'on
le perçoit c'est un peu comme une
provocation finalement parce qu'à la
lecture de l'article de Joël Denis
Bellavance si effectivement c'est
dogford qui a fait couler la goutte qui
a fait déborder le vase mais pourquoi
Justin Trudeau sort ça avec autant de
vigueur dans une entrevue au Québec un
média francophone en plus en sachant
très bien quelle réaction ça va
provoquer est-ce que des gens dans
l'entourage je me suis logo m'ont dit
aujourd'hui c'est
c'est le premier ministre qui se prépare
pour une entrevue surtout quand c'est
une entrevue avec un journaliste
d'expérience comme Joël Denis à ce
moment-là on se prépare il anticipe les
questions et prépare un peu ses réponses
il y a même des gens de son entourage
qu'il faut presque une simulation pour
dire que tu peux répondre si tu poses
tel quel question parce qu'évidemment
ces entrevues là on va s'entendre tout
de suite je suis pas en train de dire
que l'entrevue était planifié mais les
premiers ministres s'y préparent et les
lignes donc sur les la clause
dérogatoire probablement que ça faisait
un petit bout de temps qui voulait les
sortir pourquoi elle a pas saisi
l'occasion en novembre dernier pour le
faire de cette façon là pourquoi il le
sort de cette manière là à ce moment-ci
et c'est ça la grande question qui se
pose en ce moment et le spin ici à
Québec c'est de dire ben parce qu'il se
positionne pour une campagne électorale
moi c'est le spin que j'entends c'est
l'explication principale qu'il voit pour
une sortie comme ça je reviens Hélène au
pression s'exerce sur monsieur Trudeau
dans frappe Conseil des ministres ça
fait longtemps que des gens lui disent
vous devez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
encadré l'exercice de ces clauses et
rogatoire ça sent son ancien chef de
cabinet a fait un papier disant il y a
comme six mois en disant son ancien chef
de guerre monsieur Trudeau en direct
c'était la plus grande menace qui pesait
sur la démocratie canadienne donc et
pour eux c'est pas juste une clip dans
une entrevue que Joël Denis là c'est
quelque chose
auquel il croit et manifestement de
l'autre bord on dit on a d'autres une
autre philosophie
mais mais le débat il est effectivement
très intéressant
peut-être pour nous là mais la question
qu'on peut quand même se poser c'est
est-ce que ça doit être la Cour suprême
qui fait qui fait ce débat loyer et ça
quand même c'est intéressant ce que
Monsieur Trudeau nous propose nous
annonce un renvoi à la course suprême
qui par ailleurs de rentrer pas de
décision mais un avis donc ça serait pas
on ne serait pas lié par ça en passant
donc si vous voulez en changer il faut
encore faire une procédure de changement
constitutionnel alors bonjour les débats
qu'on peut compliquer mais on peut quand
même s'interroger pourquoi dès lors
qu'on a ce genre de questionnement on
renvoie tout de suite la balle vers les
tribunaux vers les juges j'ai dites nous
ce qu'il faut penser alors que on sait
très bien qu'une fois qu'on va avoir
fait ça les politiciens vont se cacher
derrière ce prétexte pour ne plus
prononcer plus dire s'ils sont d'accord
ou pas d'accord en disant on va attendre
de voir ce que les juges vont dire et
donc ce faisant
on on amène pas un débat on on on
cadenas en quelque sorte le débat on le
restreint et ça je trouve ça un peu
dommage dans dans toute cette histoire
parce que oui il y a quelque chose dont
on peut discuter mais je suis pas
certaine que ce soit seulement les juges
la course suprême qui devrait avoir un
mot à dire là-dessus ben non d'ailleurs
le chef du Parti libéral du Québec
Véronique a dit en fin de semaine ou
nous on dit ça depuis un bout qu'on ne
doit pas utiliser ce bouclier de de la
clause dérogatoire pour éviter des
jugements dans les tribunaux avant que
les jugements n'arrivent donc il a dit
d'ailleurs on avait pas attendu monsieur
Trudeau donc eux ils s'assume dans cette
position là c'est un exemple oui mais en
même temps on s'attendait à ce genre de
réaction du Parti libéral qui en quelque
part va parler aussi à sa base va parler
aux communautés culturelles etc on va
parler vraiment à son électorat mais en
même temps si le chef du Parti libéral
était pas sorti je pense que ça aurait
été pire que que la déclaration qui fait
en ce moment d'autant plus qu'il a un
caucus prévu cette semaine un caucus
professionnel puis ça va attirer
l'attention sur un autre sujet que les
déboires du Parti libéral donc c'était
sûr que le Parti libéral allait donner
cette réaction là maintenant pour ce qui
est des autres parties on rappelle que
le Québec n'a pas de riz à la
constitution puis on rappelle tous
l'émotion en fait derrière ça qui est
qui est amené de nouveau évidemment
c'est pas surprenant cette position du
syndrudo tout le monde la connaît depuis
des mois mais encore une fois comme je
disais c'est la vigueur avec laquelle il
est sorti en fin de semaine qui surprend
un petit mot conclusion là-dessus allait
qu'on n'est pas prêt de rouvrir la
condition en tout cas là elle est là la
Claude c'est un droit pour les provinces
de l'exercice
absolument on en est pas rendu à
modifier quoi que ce soit je fais juste
remarquer parce que c'est intéressant
aussi dans le débat l'attachement des
Canadiens et des Québécois à la Charte
canadienne des droits et libertés du
fait que quand on regarde les récents
sondages il y a quand même plus de
Québécois francophones qui disent que la
Cour suprême devrait trancher ses débats
et non pas par Parlement même si le
Parlement le dernier mot alors oui le
gouvernement Trudeau le goût est sorti
très très fort là-dessus est-ce que
l'opinion publique est aussi mobilisée
sur cette question là que ne les gens
François Roberge et François Legault je
pense qu'il y aurait de la pédagogie à
faire si le Québec veut gagner cette
bataille là et plus les électeurs sont
jeunes plus on a l'impression que c'est
la course prenne qui devrait avoir le
dernier mot donc c'est un débat à
plusieurs facettes qui est pas
nécessairement simple même pour les
politiciens
ok très bien on va en reparler cocus
precessionnel de Québec solidaire on va
écouter Gabriel à dos Dubois
eux là ils ont dans le viseur c'est
Henri Sainte-Anne élection partielle
puis ils veulent pas manquer leur coup
on l'écoute
nous on est prêt alors il peut choisir
la date qu'il a déclenche demain ou dans
trois semaines on est déjà sur le
terrain on est le seul parti avoir un
candidat donc notre message dans sa
récent en temps il va être très clair à
qui faites-vous confiance pour talonner
François Legault sur la question du
logement qui avez-vous vu dans les 4 5
dernières années mener cette bataille là
à Québec la réponse c'est Québec
solidaire on les a pas vu les libéraux
sur la question du logement c'est nous
quition là c'est le message qu'on va
avoir pour les électeurs de service
circonscription de l'ancienne chef du
Parti libéral madame anglaise bien sûr
qu'elle avait remporté alors Véronique
le cuez c'est un défi ils ont ils ont ça
devant il faut qu'ils gagnent c'est
l'échec ne serait pas une option comme
on dit non effectivement parce que
Québec solidaire on a eu l'impression
qu'il faisait du surplace peut-être à la
dernière élection c'est sûr que eux
répétaient sur toutes les tribunes qui
ont une vague kakis que c'est le seul
parti qui réussit à survivre à cette
vague qui acquis là que c'est le seul en
fait qui a fait un gain avec un député
de plus mais ils ont perdu aussi loin
nos Randa les attentes étaient plus
grandes que ça à la dernière campagne
électorale pour Québec solidaire parce
que c'est un particulier beaucoup de
visibilité dans les dernières années qui
s'est professionnalisé qui s'est
organisé et donc on s'attendait
peut-être à plus de gains de leur part
alors c'est sûr qu'il joue gros en fait
les deux qui ont le plus à perdre dans
cette éventuelle partielle là c'est
Québec solidaire pour les raisons que je
vous ai donné et le Parti libéral parce
que ils peuvent pas se permettre de
perdre une autre forteresse ce qui
montrer encore des problèmes au niveau
du recrutement au niveau du financement
puis frais accentuer en fait la descente
encore une fois du Parti libéral pour ce
qui est de la CAQ en ce moment c'est
comme si on voulait pas monter les
attentes qu'on regarde un petit peu la
partie jouer ensemble
c'est pas ils ont pas encore non c'est
pas encore donc ça va être à suivre
c'est intéressant
honnêtement si Québec solidaire ne
parvient pas à Rachid cette
circonscription là alors qu'ils ont fini
deuxième par - 3000 voix d'écart 3000
euros ça peut avoir l'air beaucoup mais
ça se renverse surtout dans une élection
partielle et pendant que la partie
libérale n'a pas de chef n'a toujours
pas de candidats sur le terrain un
moment donné je comprends avec les
Québec solidaire faut gagner cette
circonscription là normalement elle est
dans la séquence de gains de Québec
solidaire dans la prochaine entre je
cherche le bon mot mais prochaine batch
prochain lot de 5 construction qu'on
devrait gagner ce Québec solidaire pour
suivre sa progression donc pour eux oui
on joue beaucoup plus gros que pour les
autres partis politiques pour la partie
libérale en deuxième je suis d'accord
avec Véronique on veut garder cette
forteresse là mais on s'attend à ce que
Québec on s'attend presque Québec
solidaire l'emporte alors une défaite ça
serait vraiment très très difficile à
supporter ils l'ont dans livre comme on
dit donc s'il perdent encore ça fait
plus mal oui Hélène
oui en fait je suis d'accord avec mes
deux collègues en fait la bataille c'est
libérale Québec solidaire effectivement
si les libéraux perdent on va dire aïe
aïe c'est la déconfiture qui se poursuit
et inversement si Québec solidaire faire
et ben on va dire bah voilà ils ne sont
pas capables de progresser pour eux
l'image d'une victoire dans une
circonscription là elle serait très
puissante aussi parce que ça serait bon
gagné le siège de l'ancienne chef du
Parti libéral l'ancienne chef de
l'opposition officielle donc voilà ça
prouve ce que l'on dit que nous sommes
Québec solidaire malgré une députation
plus faible nous sommes la véritable
opposition alors pour eux les enjeux
sont importants une dernière très vite
on a vu les chiffres sur les le les
autos sur les ponts de Québec Véronique
ça ce n'est pas revenu à un niveau
prépondémique donc il y a pas les
problèmes de circulation qu'on peut
connaître dans une ville comme Montréal
encore on voit les chiffres
c'est ça va c'est est-ce que ça ça vient
de tirer sur le troisième infirmière ou
pas encore ben c'est sûr que ça met la
table pour cette réunion de la CAQ qui
est prévue cette semaine je vous parlais
que c'est la saison des caucus
professionnels comme on dit là les
députés les ministres tout ça qui se
réunissent pour préparer la session
parlementaire je pense qu'ils peuvent
s'attendre à ce que il y a beaucoup de
questions sur ce sujet là ça c'est
certain d'où tu as plus qu'à campagne
électorale François Legault m'a donné
avait signifié son impatience il était
tellement tanné qu'on lui parle du
troisième lien mais je pense avoir venir
c'est pas fini
ça commence non surtout qu'on devrait
avoir les études là bientôt là qui
montre à quel point c'est nécessaire on
a c'est imminent d'après Bernard de
Raville quelque part 2023
la sortie de ce panel que je ne peux pas
déplacer hélène a très bientôt Véronique
Alex merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI